Uważamy, że komputery kwantowe pozwolą nam rozwiązywać niektóre problemy szybciej niż możemy to zrobić za pomocą samych komputerów klasycznych. Ale
rozumienie tego, jak to jest możliwe, jest subtelne. Dzisiaj w Qiskit w klasie spróbujemy odkryć źródło mocy
obliczeń kwantowych, przyglądając się jednemu z pierwszych
algorytmów. Witaj w Qiskit w klasie. W tej serii będziemy używać Qiskit, aby zgłębiać fundamentalne
koncepcje powszechnie omawiane na kursach związanych z obliczeniami kwantowymi. Każdemu filmowi towarzyszy interaktywny moduł
podlinkowany w opisie poniżej, więc koniecznie go sprawdź. Jeśli dużo słyszałeś o komputerach kwantowych, prawdopodobnie
słyszałeś, że mogą używać zjawisk kwantowych jak superpozycja, splątanie i interferencja, żeby rozwiązywać
problemy w sposób, w jaki komputery klasyczne nie potrafią. Ale jak dokładnie te cechy pomagają? W 1985 roku David Deutsch był
pierwszym, który pokazał, jak to może się stać. Wymyślił to, co nazywa się teraz algorytmem Deutscha, który mógł rozwiązać
problem sprawniej niż algorytm klasyczny. Dzisiaj przyjrzymy się algorytmowi Deutscha i
jego późniejszemu rozszerzeniu zwanemu algorytmem Deutscha-Jozy, oraz zbadamy, jak unikalne kwantowe aspekty qubitów
mogą być użyte z korzyścią dla komputera kwantowego. Następnie uruchomimy te algorytmy na prawdziwym komputerze kwantowym z Qiskit.
Istnieją inne algorytmy kwantowe, które również wykazują teoretyczną przewagę nad znanymi algorytmami klasycznymi. I nie wszystkie z nich działają
na tych samych zasadach co te, które zobaczymy dzisiaj. Więc to, czego się dzisiaj nauczymy, nie wyjaśnia ogólnie, jak działa komputer kwantowy,
ale pomaga nam zacząć widzieć, jak zasady mechaniki kwantowej mogą być łączone,
żeby stworzyć potężny komputer kwantowy. Zanim zagłębimy się w algorytm Deutscha, zastanówmy się najpierw, jak komputery kwantowe
różnią się od komputerów klasycznych i jak mogłoby to dać nam przewagę w rozwiązywaniu pewnych
problemów. Jedną z różnic jest to, że bity kwantowe, zwane qubitami, mogą być w stanach superpozycji. Zamiast być
ograniczone do stanu zero lub stanu jeden jak klasyczny bit, qubit
może być w stanie superpozycji zarówno zera, jak i jedynki. Zapisujemy ten stan tak,
gdzie a i b to liczby zespolone, których kwadraty sumują się do jedności. I im więcej
qubitów, tym bardziej ta przepaść się rozszerza. Dwa bity mogą być wciąż tylko w jednym z tych
czterech możliwych stanów: 0 0, 0 1, 1 0 lub 1
1. Dwa qubity mogą być w superpozycji wszystkich czterech tych klasycznie dozwolonych stanów, co jest
zapisane w taki sposób. Ogólnie, klasyczny układ n bitów może być tylko w jednym z 2 do n możliwych
kombinacji zer i jedynek. Kwantowy układ n qubitów może być w superpozycji wszystkich 2 do n tych
stanów. Skalowanie jest wykładnicze. Więc nawet gdybyśmy mieli tylko 10 qubitów,
mogłyby być w stanie superpozycji 2 do 10, czyli 1024 możliwych kombinacji zer i
jedynek. Wykładnicze skalowanie przestrzeni stanów qubitów nazywa się
zrównolegleniem kwantowym i jest częściowo odpowiedzialne za przewagę komputerów kwantowych nad klasycznymi. Ale komputer kwantowy
to nie tylko masowy procesor równoległy. Sam fakt, że qubity w komputerze kwantowym mogą być w
superpozycji wykładniczo wielu stanów, nie oznacza, że mamy dostęp do wszystkich informacji w każdym z tych
stanów. Ponieważ pomiar zawala układ do jednego stanu lub innego. Zobaczmy,
jak to się rozgrywa w prostym problemie. Powiedzmy, że jest jakaś maszyna, do której
możesz podać jeden bit. Maszyna zastosuje do niego pewną funkcję i wypluje inny bit. Maszyna
jest w czarnej skrzynce, do której nie mamy dostępu. Mamy dostęp tylko do bitu,
który podajemy – x, i bitu, który skrzynka wypluwa – f z x.
Chcemy ustalić, jaka jest funkcja f stosowana przez maszynę.
Istnieją cztery możliwe funkcje, które zamieniają jeden bit na drugi bit.
Żeby dowiedzieć się, jaka to funkcja, możemy po prostu podać jej zero i zobaczyć, czy wypluje zero czy jeden. Następnie podać
jedynkę i zrobić to samo. Każdy z tych dwóch kroków nazywa się zapytaniem. To
jest jeden sposób porównywania algorytmów klasycznych i kwantowych – przez tzw. model zapytań, gdzie porównujemy liczbę
zapytań, które każdy z algorytmów musi zadać czarnej skrzynce, żeby rozwiązać problem. Więc w tym przypadku nasza
metoda klasyczna musiała dwukrotnie zapytać skrzynkę, żeby poznać funkcję. Zobaczmy, czy możemy zrobić lepiej, jeśli mamy komputer kwantowy
zapytujący czarną skrzynkę. Zamiast najpierw podawać zero, a potem jedynkę,
komputer kwantowy może podać skrzynce qubit będący w superpozycji zera i
jedynki. Więc w efekcie podajemy skrzynce oba wejścia jednym zapytaniem. Czy
to oznacza, że możemy poznać funkcję jednym zapytaniem?
Niestety tak nie jest. Widzimy, dlaczego ten pomysł zawodzi, gdy testujemy go na komputerze kwantowym. Zrobimy
circuit z dwoma qubitami. Qubit zero, reprezentowany tutaj przez tę górną linię, będzie naszym stanem wejściowym X, który podajemy do
czarnej skrzynki, pokazanej tutaj jako bordowa bramka oznaczona UF. Bramka UF jest
zaprojektowana tak, żeby wziąć qubit zero jako stan wejściowy X, a następnie zastosować transformację na qubitcie jeden, która przenosi
stan zero do stanu f z x. Więc dopóki qubit 1 zaczynał w stanie
zero, wyjście to x na qubicie 0 i f z x na qubicie 1. Żeby znaleźć f z x dla
zarówno x=0, jak i x=1 jednocześnie, możemy spróbować umieścić qubit 0 w superpozycji 0 i 1 przed
podaniem go do czarnej skrzynki. Robi to ta czerwona bramka Hadamard, która przekształca stan zero do 1/√2 |0⟩
+ |1⟩. Więc po bramce czarnej skrzynki powinniśmy teraz mieć superpozycję obu
f z 0 i f z 1 na qubicie 1. Gdy mierzymy dwa qubity, mamy nadzieję udzielić
odpowiedzi na pytanie: jaka funkcja jest w czarnej skrzynce? Użyjmy prymitywu Qiskit sampler, żeby uruchomić
circuit i zwrócić wynik. Możemy wybrać liczbę uruchomień circuit, zwaną próbkami, zmieniając ten
parametr zwany shots tutaj.
WEBVTT
Jest to równoważne liczbie zapytań, które zadajemy czarnej skrzynce. Zobaczmy, czy jedno zapytanie
wystarczy. Oto wynik. Zmierzyliśmy qubit 0 jako zero – to była wartość wejściowa x, i qubit 1 jako 1 – to była wartość wyjściowa f z x. Więc teraz
wiemy, że f z 0 równa się 1. Ale co z f z 1? Tutaj leży problem. Gdy
zmierzyliśmy stan, superpozycje zawaliły się i udało nam się zmierzyć tylko jedną część funkcji jednym
zapytaniem. To nie mówi nam wszystkiego, czego potrzebujemy, żeby ustalić, jaka to funkcja. Potrzebowalibyśmy
drugiego zapytania skrzynki do tego. Więc choć zasada zrównoleglenia kwantowego pozwala nam jednocześnie
zlecać czarnej skrzynce ewaluację f z 0 i f z 1, nie mamy dostępu do obu
tych odpowiedzi. Samo zrównoleglenie kwantowe nie wystarczy. Algorytm Deutscha
pokazuje, jak możemy użyć zrównoleglenia kwantowego nieco inaczej, żeby dowiedzieć się o funkcji w czarnej skrzynce. Nie będziemy
w stanie dowiedzieć się dokładnie, jaka jest funkcja, ale będziemy w stanie dowiedzieć się czegoś nowego o niej jednym
zapytaniem, czego nie moglibyśmy zrobić klasycznym komputerem. Zacznijmy od spojrzenia na tabelę czterech możliwych
funkcji zamieniających jeden bit na jeden bit. Tutaj widać, że dwie z funkcji f_pod_1 i f_pod_4 zawsze
zwracają jedną wartość niezależnie od stanu wejściowego. Nazywamy te dwie funkcje
stałymi. f_pod_2 i f_pod_3 zwrócą zero lub jeden w zależności od
stanu x. Nazywamy te dwie funkcje zbalansowanymi. Algorytm Deutscha
ustala, czy funkcja jest stała czy zbalansowana, dokonując sprytnych modyfikacji circuit, którego używaliśmy
poprzednio. Oto circuit. Zaczyna od przygotowania qubitu 0 w stanie 1/√2 |0⟩
+ |1⟩ za pomocą Hadamarda jak poprzednio, i qubitu 1 w stanie 1/√2 |0⟩ − |1⟩
za pomocą bramki NOT, po której następuje Hadamard.
Więc pełny stan w tym miejscu wygląda tak, gdzie to jest stan qubitu 0 i
to jest stan qubitu 1. Przygotowanie qubitu jeden w taki sposób, zamiast po prostu
zostawić go w stanie zero, pozwala algorytmowi użyć zrównoleglenia kwantowego w połączeniu z interferencją, żeby się dowiedzieć
o funkcji czarnej skrzynki. Zobaczmy jak: gdy qubity są podawane do UF – bramki czarnej skrzynki – może się zdarzyć kilka rzeczy.
Jeśli funkcja jest stała, czarna skrzynka wykona pewną operację na qubicie jeden samym w sobie, niezależnie
od stanu zera. W tym przypadku, ponieważ UF nie dotyka qubitu zero ani nie dba o jego stan, drugi Hadamard tutaj po prostu cofnie to, co
zrobił pierwszy Hadamard,
i zmierzymy qubit jako będący w stanie zero. Przyjrzyjmy się zbalansowanej funkcji f_pod_2 jako przykładowi, żeby zobaczyć,
co UF robi ze stanem w tym przypadku. Gdy x wynosi zero, f z x wynosi zero, i gdy x
wynosi 1, f z x wynosi 1. Pamiętaj, co powiedziałem o bramce UF: bierze qubit 0
jako nasz stan wejściowy x i wyprowadza f z x na qubicie 1, zakładając, że qubit 1
zaczął w stanie zero. Więc dla tej funkcji to, co UF robi z qubitem 1, zależy
od qubitu 0. Jeśli 0 wynosi zero, qubit 1 zostanie w stanie zero, żeby uzyskać f
z x równe 0. Jeśli qubit 0 wynosi 1, czarna skrzynka zastosuje bramkę NOT do qubitu 1 i umieści
go w stanie jeden. Więc dostajemy f z 1 równe 1. To jest dokładnie to, co robi bramka kontrolowanego NOT, czyli cnot.
Bramka cnot bierze dwa qubity, qubit kontrolny i qubit docelowy, i odwraca
stan qubitu docelowego, jeśli qubit kontrolny jest w stanie jeden. Ale nic nie robi docelowemu, jeśli kontrolny
jest w stanie zero. Więc UF dla F2 to po prostu cnot na Q0 i Q1. Bramka
cnot nic nie zrobi z pierwszym składnikiem, ponieważ qubit kontrolny jest w stanie zero. Ale na drugim składniku to
zero odwraca się do jeden i to jeden odwraca się do zero. I jeśli wyciągniemy minus, zobaczymy, że stan qubitu 1 jest
niezmieniony. Ale ten składnik zebrał minus. Więc to qubit 0 jest tym,
który się zmienił. Przeszedł ze stanu 0 + 1 do stanu 0 minus
1. Gdy stosujemy końcowy Hadamard do qubitu 0, transformuje go do stanu 1. Więc jeśli funkcja w czarnej skrzynce
to f_pod_2, zmierzymy jeden zamiast zero. Okazuje się, że bramka UF dla drugiej zbalansowanej funkcji f3 to
ta sama bramka cnot, po której następuje NOT na qubicie 1. Ta końcowa bramka NOT nie wpływa na qubit zero. Więc gdy funkcja
jest zbalansowana, zmierzymy qubit 0 jako będący w stanie jeden na końcu circuit. Jeśli nie do końca
podążałeś za tym wszystkim, to w porządku. Sugeruję, żebyś przeszedł przez to samodzielnie, żeby zobaczyć, jak to działa. Główny punkt tutaj to to, co
wydarzyło się, gdy zastosowaliśmy cnot dla dwóch zbalansowanych funkcji. Qubit 0 był używany tylko jako qubit kontrolny do zmiany
stanu qubitu 1. Intuicyjnie możesz myśleć, że qubit 0 pozostanie niezmieniony. A jednak w jakiś sposób nasze
operacje na qubicie jeden faktycznie zmieniają stan qubitu zero, zmieniając względną fazę między dwiema częściami jego
superpozycji. To zjawisko znane jest jako mechanizm odbicia fazowego i jest
bardzo nieintuicyjne, jak wiele zjawisk kwantowych. W pewnym sensie możesz myśleć o mechanizmie odbicia fazowego
jak o wiosłowaniu w łódce. Akt odpychania wody do tyłu faktycznie napędza cię do przodu. Tak jak operacje na
qubicie 1 faktycznie zmieniają qubit zero. Teraz możemy uruchomić algorytm Deutscha na
Qiskit. Tutaj możemy wybrać, którą funkcję umieścić w czarnej skrzynce – wybraliśmy F3. Oto
diagram circuit algorytmu i możemy go uruchomić jak poprzednio z prymitywem sampler. Ustawimy liczbę
próbek na tylko jedną i zobaczmy, co mierzymy. W tym przypadku zmierzyliśmy jeden.
Więc wiemy, że funkcja była zbalansowana, co jest rzeczywiście tym, czego oczekiwaliśmy, skoro czarna skrzynka zawierała funkcję f3. Więc jednym
zapytaniem byliśmy w stanie odróżnić między tymi dwiema klasami funkcji.
Klasyczny algorytm potrzebowałby dwóch zapytań, żeby to ustalić. To pokazuje skromną przewagę obliczeń
kwantowych nad klasycznymi, ale nie jest to zbyt imponujące – jedno zamiast dwóch. Ale algorytm Deutscha
jest nadal niezwykle ważny dla historii obliczeń kwantowych, ponieważ dostarczył iskry, która skłoniła innych do myślenia o większych, bardziej wyrafinowanych algorytmach kwantowych.
WEBVTT
jest nadal niezwykle ważny dla historii obliczeń kwantowych, ponieważ dostarczył iskry, która skłoniła innych
do myślenia o większych, bardziej wyrafinowanych algorytmach kwantowych.
Obejmuje to wieloqubitowe rozszerzenie algorytmu Deutscha, które demonstruje znacznie bardziej imponującą kwantową przewagę.
Nazywa się algorytm Deutscha-Jozy. Rozwiązuje podobny problem, ale w tym przypadku funkcja czarnej skrzynki,
o której chcemy się dowiedzieć, bierze n bitów jako wejście i wyprowadza jeden bit. Jak
poprzednio, obiecano nam, że funkcja jest albo stała – co oznacza, że bit wyjściowy jest zawsze jeden lub zawsze zero,
niezależnie od ciągu bitów wejściowych – albo zbalansowana, co oznacza, że wynik wynosi zero dla
połowy ciągów bitów wejściowych i jeden dla drugiej połowy. Istnieją oczywiście inne
funkcje, które zamieniają n bitów na jeden bit i nie są ani stałe, ani zbalansowane. Ale w tym problemie
obiecano nam, że żadna z tych funkcji nie jest w czarnej skrzynce. Ta w skrzynce jest gwarantowanie albo stała,
albo zbalansowana. Circuit Deutscha-Jozy wygląda podobnie do algorytmu Deutscha, ale z większą liczbą qubitów. Tutaj mamy
implementację algorytmu Deutscha-Jozy do uczenia się o funkcji trzybitowej. Tym razem mamy trzy qubity
dla stanu wejściowego zamiast tylko jednego. A następnie mamy ten ostatni qubit dla stanu wyjściowego. Jak poprzednio,
przygotowujemy wszystkie wejściowe qubity w stanie 0 + 1, a wyjściowy qubit
w stanie 0 minus 1. Następnie, choć matematyka jest nieco bardziej skomplikowana do śledzenia, zasada
pozostaje ta sama. Jeśli funkcja jest stała, nie będzie zależeć od trzech górnych qubitów. Więc ich stany
przekształcą się z powrotem do zera po drugich Hadamardach i nasz pomiar da trzybitowy ciąg samych
zer. Ale jeśli funkcja jest zbalansowana, to gdy mierzymy qubity po Hadamardach, mechanizm
odbicia fazowego spowoduje, że jeden lub więcej z tych bitów będzie jeden. Może to nie być tak łatwe do zobaczenia tym razem, ale jeśli prześledziłeś
każdy krok samodzielnie, wkrótce zobaczysz, że tak musi być. Jednym ze sposobów sprawdzenia jest próba obliczenia
prawdopodobieństwa zmierzenia samych zer przy zbalansowanej funkcji. Powinno być zero. Uruchommy
algorytm Deutscha-Jozy na komputerze kwantowym z Qiskit. Najtrudniejszym krokiem jest prawdopodobnie tworzenie funkcji Deutscha-Jozy.
To będzie nasza czarna skrzynka, którą tutaj zapytujemy. Ten kod produkuje losową funkcję Deutscha-Jozy, która jest
gwarantowanie albo zbalansowana, albo stała. Następnie tworzymy nasz circuit Deutscha-Jozy, wstawiając naszą czarną skrzynkę
tutaj. Ponownie uruchamiamy circuit z sampler i po pomiarze patrzymy na
zmierzone bity, żeby ustalić, czy funkcja była zbalansowana czy stała.
Jeśli wszystkie są zero, jest stała. Ale jeśli w ciągu jest przynajmniej jeden bit jeden, to jest zbalansowana. W tym
przypadku dostajemy ciąg bitów 1 1 1.
Więc wiemy, że funkcja była zbalansowana. Mam nadzieję, że dałem ci pierwszy wgląd w to, jak algorytmy kwantowe
mogą korzystać z interesujących i często subtelnych zjawisk kwantowych, żeby uzyskać przewagę nad klasycznymi
algorytmami. Prawdopodobnie też zauważyłeś, jak trudne może być projektowanie algorytmów kwantowych. Nawet ten pierwszy
wymagał dużej kreatywności, żeby osiągnąć tylko skromną wygraną nad metodami klasycznymi. I od tego pierwszego algorytmu
fizycy i informatycy nadal wymyślają niesamowicie pomysłowe sposoby wykorzystania mechaniki kwantowej
na swoją korzyść, w tym dalsze rozszerzenia i zastosowania algorytmu Deutscha-Jozy. Jeśli chcesz
dowiedzieć się o niektórych z nich, a także samemu wypróbować algorytmy Deutscha i Deutscha-Jozy, zajrzyj do
modułu podlinkowanego w opisie, żeby zacząć. Dzięki za oglądanie i do zobaczenia następnym razem.